before i was at tasty i was living and
working in stockholm sweden and i always
used to joke that the swedes had a bun
for every single season and the bun for
the winter season is luciboular hey hey
i'm alex i'm a tasty producer and today
i'm going to show you guys how to make
lucilla or saffron buns lucivilla are so
beautiful but don't let that intimidate
you in making them they're actually
pretty simple now some people might
grind up their saffron threads into a
fine powder however i found that once
you're done kneading the dough the
saffron threads have pretty much
dissolved into it so i just throw them
right in saffron buns are rich and
buttery like a brioche they have a
little bit of sweetness a little bit of
spice and of course a vibrant yellow
color from the saffron infused dough
cardamom isn't traditionally put in most
saffron buns but i like to add a little
bit just to give it an extra punch in
flavor
flavor punch
i found it easier to make a well and put
the wet ingredients into that well and
slowly start incorporating the flour
into the wet that way and that will help
you to incorporate the ingredients
completely and not end up with a lumpy
dough because no one wants a lumpy dough
even in the dark in the cold christmas
time in sweden was my absolute favorite
time of year there's christmas markets
pretty lights everywhere snow and of
course saffron buttons unfortunately
they're only really available in
december but in learning how to make
them you could eat them all year long
kneading the dough is a super important
step in order to develop the gluten and
get a really light and fluffy bun you
can find these buns in december in
bakeries across scandinavia but they're
actually meant to be eaten on december
13th which is santa lucia day the
festival of light and it's meant to
bring light and warmth to the coldest
month of the year
punching down the dough will help
release some of those gas bubbles and
redistribute the use of the dough first
i pull off some of the dough and form a
ball the ball should be about two inches
in width and then i start rolling out
that ball into a long rope if you want
super even sized buns you can measure
your dough throughout this shaping
process but i usually just eyeball it
traditionally they're shaped in an s
shape meant to look like a curled up cat
and that's why they're also sometimes
called lucicator
proofing is the final rise of the shaped
bread dough before baking and it's an
important step so don't skip it the egg
wash will help give a really beautiful
golden brown and shiny finish to the
buns while baking
i miss sweden so much but making these
buns it's like a little piece of sweden
right here in california so
traditionally the buns have two raisins
that are placed in the center of each
spiral and these are meant to look like
the eyes of the cat which i don't know
if i particularly see but hey can't
complain once these buns go into the
oven
buns in the oven
10 to 12 minutes and you'll have a
delicious lucibola ready to eat when i'm
traveling my absolute favorite way to
absorb another culture is through the
food but if you don't have the
opportunity to travel learning how to
make other cultures dishes at home is a
great way to explore
brings me right back now those are some
good looking buns
oh yes
[Music]
you